good afternoon
uh welcome to the 31st quizness memorial
lecture organized by economic growth
center i'm rohini pandey a professor in
the economics department and the
director of egc
the kuznets memorial lecture is an
annual lecture on issues of economic
development given by a prominent
economist in memory of simon kuznets who
helped found the economic growth center
in 1961.
professor kuznets went on to win the
nobel prize for i quote empirically
founded interpretation of economic
growth which has led to new and deepened
insight into the economic and social
structure and processes of development
today as yale's hub for economics
research and teaching on issues
concerning lower income economies and
advancement of their populations we
continue to advance this agenda
simon kuznets studied economics at the
kharkiv national university in ukraine
before migrating to the united states
like this lecture series the school
where kuznets began his studies now
bears his name the simon kuznets kharkiv
national university of economics
the fact that that city is under attack
and the school has been bombed is a
stark symbol of how politics touches
every aspect of life and how economics
cannot be understood without taking
power into account
this year the lecture will be presented
by professor leonard banchikun a scholar
whose life and research have contributed
to our understanding of the
intersections between economics and
political power
an accomplished scholar in many fields
professor van chikun's research spans
areas such as clientelism and state
capture
resource course and democratization
where he has implemented field
experiments with politicians competing
in real elections to investigate voting
behavior and election outcomes
since 2015 he has been a professor of
politics and international affairs at
princeton university
as well as an associate of faculty in
economics and he has previously served
as a professor in new york university
and at yale university where he was also
an egc affiliate
professor banshee kuhn has also been a
leader in diversifying the economics
profession
in 2014 he opened the african school of
economics in benin with a mission to
produce world-renowned social scientists
and economic leaders on the continent
esc has broadened the pipeline of young
african scholars entering leading
graduate programs economics and
political science and we are very
grateful for leonard's leadership here
today's lecture and the related
conference tomorrow organized by
professor wansha kyun and nathan cannon
of the university of houston focus on
the subject of political distortions and
economic development
finally just before we start some
logistics we will record this evening's
program and post it online for public
view so please be aware that your your
presence here is in effect permission to
broadcast your image and any questions
you ask in the q a
i'll also like to welcome those who are
joining us via the zoom webinar please
feel free to submit questions uh on the
zoom chat for question the q a
and finally i would like to thank the
egc staff and students have really
helped make us this make this event
happen a big thank you to western
mcintyre and boomi okagoya on
communications and dina diana ford ben
king and especially noel sardella for
all that hard work now please join me in
welcoming professor wanjiku into the
stage
thank you
okay so um thanks rainey for such a
generous introduction
um
today i will be speaking about political
distortion
and
economic development
it's a topic that i i was having
interested in studying
and doing something about
since i was in middle school
this is a picture of me on the left
as a political activist
you know trying to do something about
political distortion autocracies in the
name in the 80s
then later on when i started my phd
my first
at northwestern my first paper my first
proposal was actually about political
mechanism in economic development
so
for 30 years i've been waiting for the
opportunity to actually
talk about political distortion and i'm
so grateful for agc
for giving me this opportunity
and
it's never late you know
so you can notice that it was one check
on there so
later on i changed the spelling of my
name to w and you have some interesting
comments by my then advisor
michael baldwin you know very very
generous
um
so the talk will be structured with an
introduction to motivate the topic i'll
be covering
and
uh
provide critical benchmarks
and then
the empirics of political distortion
on
three aspects
one is border induce
political distortion like political
distortion that induce a relationship
between politicians and voters
called patronage or clientelism
denomination
and then film firm induced distortion
which is uh
under
labeled political connections and then
i'll talk about state capture which is a
more systemic
deep
form of political distortion
and i think
what i hope will be the highlight of the
talk will be about remedies
and
i'm going to cover
you know several aspects of
how political distortion can be
mitigated
with um
public management with political
selection
and then something that i will explain
to you later that i call public reason
which is how you get the public
to be engaged in the process of policy
making and i will provide direction for
future research
as a way as a way of introduction
so
recent macroeconomic literature
emphasized the role of misallocation of
production factors
at the micro level sorry i think i
should be nice yeah sorry
um so as a way of background you know
differences in living standard across
countries are large persistent
and driven by growth
and those differences are
due to productivity gaps and
misallocation
um
the key fact that
um will motivate
our
our our study here is that these
disparities in livable capital account
for at most 50 percent of differences in
income per capita
so
there is room for
institutions
to play
in government to play a very very very
important role
to get the economy
to the
to an optimal allocation
of uh product production factors
so throughout the talk
there will be um
some focus
on first best allocation
and distortion being a deviation from
this first best
you know first best allocation
together
with
some
political
aspect
so um
i think okay all right
um
political institutions now
it's established that they have very
very important
impact
on growth
and they affect
growth through their influence on
governance and state capacity
and it's also
mechanism
political institutions a mechanism for
selection of policy
office holders
the menu of policy decision
and the logic of enforcement
of those policies
so
um there have been
a wide range of
coverage of political institutions
particularly by simon robinson in their
2016
book
which associate
economic institution um
as to prosperity
that emerged from a balanced
increase in state capacity and this
regional power
but
what is also key is that there are a
whole sector of society
without power
that need to be included
and these so redistribution of resources
is actually
key to prosperity
and
if reducing resources redistribution in
general is key to prosperity
then political institutions have to
allow for which is empowered
to act as principle
so institutions that
should be also accountable to the needs
of the poor
and institutions that have capacity
to meet those needs
so
as i mentioned earlier so there is
um a wise
uh range of
work
on historical institutions
colonial prequel institution
rationalization
and eternity of
ethnicity and culture
that have
great impact on growth
so that literature has provide insights
on the origin of institutions and its
effect
but it has
limited i should say
policy implications
and sometimes might be
misread as historical determinism
so
um
you know as i mentioned roman son and
co-authors have empirically established
that history may account for at most 50
percent
of
development outcome
in my own work
i show we show that slavery
particularly in africa
has important long-term impact on
development through trust
and their personal trust
but it'll explain
between 15 and 25 percent of variation
in trust level
so clearly history matter
history play an important
role
in current development level
but it's account for a fraction
of the variation development outcome
so
what is also important to note
is that
there is a growing evidence suggesting
that countries with similar level
[Music]
let's say country with similar history
similar historical trajectories
have a wide range of development
outcomes not only across countries but
even within countries
so
this
convergence
shows that institutions
and policy matter for development
in fact history can be overcome history
is a constraint
but with policy with institutional
design
its effect can be mitigated
so um i have this graph
uh from uh
a recent paper by uh creme and cauters
showing for instance how
that is how we have convergence in
institutional level
around the world particularly between
africa and asia and africa the rest of
the world
so what i'm going to be focusing on this
lecture
is
instead of asking whether institution
contributes to growth
is to focus on what type of institutions
are most effective for growth
and how they can be implemented
what is the role of
controversial policies
for institutional experimentation
for instance antarctic law
decentralization policy deliberation
and
i have been particularly inspired by the
recent experience of china
pre-1975 the focus was on
absolute absolutism and cultural
revolution
and communism
but now the focus is instead on
institutional reform
public management decentralization and
policy experimentation
so let me start by explaining a little
bit what is political distortion
so when a political system induces money
political system and use choices that
are suboptimal in terms of welfare and
development outcome
they affect human capital formation
innovation they affect
capital investment
through regulated policies and
procurement
they affect spatial friction
misallocation infrastructure spending
market destruction
and
those distortion political distortion
can be complementary to other distortion
and development in macroeconomy like
transportation information and market
access
so what we need to do
is
to provide benchmark let's look at
benchmark
that will tell us something about what
the optimal
public investment
should
be what is the optimal
institutions arrangement to promote
innovation and technological change
and then
we will present departure from those
mess mark as political distortion
we will document how the distortion
leads to misallocation of public
investment in state capture
and then later on as i mentioned earlier
we are going to discuss what policies
can alleviate the distortion
so
um
for the interest of time
i'm going to focus on two
benchmark model
uh one is by battle 1990 that contracted
growth model that include public
services as a productive input for
private producers
so it's a model of government the role
of government
in the economy particularly in terms of
public investment
and
the focus is on publicly provided goods
that are subject to congestion you know
that which are rival
but to some extent non-excludable
like highways
water installation
courts and so on
and an individual decision to expand its
own capital in that model
enhanced outputs congest the facility
available to other producers
so the growth rate
in that economy is subdocument and there
is a room for income tax
over lump sum tax
to to to
to get to the optimal
level of allocation
uh in that economy
so
what is
what we draw from this is that
when for instance
taxes
are
when for instance there are taxes
that target
taxes or investment
that target co-ed needs attack target
interest groups
is a clear distortion
from what is the optimal public
investment
so
the other model
focusing on innovation and market
competition
uh gives
by aguero and cultures
give a
shmpatherium group model in which firms
innovates until they succeed
then block others market entry the setup
is one in which the final output
yt is equal to
80 the technology
and there are uh
advanced sectors
where innovation happens
in backward sectors
that
there is no innovation
and in each sector there is no there is
an incumbent and a potential entrant
and in the model only potential entrance
innovates
and
there is the decision make to end to
invest in ind
in order to replace the incumbent
decision made by
you know in the product
productive sector
and if
successful productivity in that sector
increased by some factor
and the new intern
take over the market
otherwise the incumbent remains
monopolist and productivity is given by
you know
ajt ajt minus one
so mbdrive
derived from the model
two
one
two key result the one is that
democracy
is
democracy has when democracy increases
when the level of democracy one level of
competition increases
then uh it's more likely for
um
the
for the incumbent
to be replaced
so um the key
uh the average growth is given by this
uh by this equation
and
this is increasing in democracy
and democracy is more growth enhancing
when you are close to the technology
frontier
you know so i think it's
it's an important paper showing
the value of democracy for innovation
and technological progress
and also the value of democracy in
maintaining market competition
market competition based on productivity
based on innovation
as opposed to political connection
so um the
there are
country evidence to support
uh this um
insight uh from this paper by uh again
alexina and trevi okay so
uh there are other benchmark you know
besides one focusing on
um
public investment
the one on innovation there are other
benchmark uh we focus on redistribution
uh also focus on threat of appropriation
concert enforcement
and
in
all these models
a political incentive can meaningfully
distort economic outcome and welfare
so
um
okay
so now
let's move away from this relationship
benchmark um to
to to look at the empirical questions
that we can derive from richmond mark
so the first is that how
democracy affect public investment
how political connection affect
innovation market competition and
procurement for instance
and
can we quantify
um
the gdp and welfare loss due to
those connections and what kind of
policy can be put in place
to curb those uh distortion
so
um
okay
all right so i'm going to start with
the volume juice distortion percolation
directly linking
decision in public investment
to
um
an incentive to win vote or win
political support
so um
we are going to use an illustration of
politicos
or of water-induced political distortion
but patronage
the work by burgess and now
as an example
where
we look at effect of road expenditure on
coetnits
depending on
whether um the country has a detector
ship
or a democracy
there are other similar works
but the focus here will be on um
on that
seminal paper
in in kenya so this picture shows for
instance
um how
um road expenditure respond to
democratic breakdown
so
um
from
from 1960 to 79
you have democracy
from 79 to
uh
to i think from 70 i'm sorry from seven
to 70 to to 80 you have an autocracy
and
there is a leadership change
in 1980
you know and then later on you have
democracy with leadership change
so we have two
[Music]
you have two first of all with democracy
breakdown and leadership change
and the question is how
investment
in roads or road maintenance respond
to those kind of political incentives
and you can see from the picture
under democracy
there is
smaller much smaller gap
between
um
ethnics and co-ethnics
a much bigger gap between ethnic ethnics
and autocracies
so
when you look at
um
which ethnicity it is in
you know
is in charge
you see that there is even even the
ethnic group that have been excluded
from power have less investment than the
ethnic group
in power
but then the ethnic groups have never
been power
you know the the level of uh road
investment uh is
hasn't it
does not respond democratic breakdown
so
um this map is very very interesting
because
it shows what
um
the roads network should have been
if it was based on population and market
access
and then what roads map the sort of the
roads are you know under democracy
and autocracy you can see
the deviation from first best with
deviation from washington factual
road
network of roads investment
that respond to market incentives and
population
um it's
the the gap between that and the actual
network is smaller on the democracy than
it is on the autocracy
so clearly
democracy is better
as
allocating
fairly
optimally road networks
i mean road investment i'm sorry okay
so
one another example um
i talked about public investment but
another investment that the government
had made is investing to protect
property rights
and
uh chris
goldstein and u3 have a paper in which
they show how
those
in power you know
the chiefs and
the
elites
they tend to invest more in new
technology
to protect i mean
more productive technology
because the fear we have less fear
that
the asset will be sized that
their property right will be respected
and in that model
they they show
that um
lack of security of property rights
uh creates
uh distortion in an investment
where
um you know the elite
can invest
in following
to increase production and productivity
and
those not in power
much less
and it has an important it has an
implication for for gender
because for instance women are
particularly penalized not only because
they rally hold office
but because of uh you know gender gap
in uh
in in illinois
okay
so
um
sabrine begs uh 2001 to
2021 paper on um on patreon paternalism
economic dependency in pakistan also
another dimension
of uh
distortion
which
based on the structural dependence of
rural
farmers
on political elite
who have them as
tenants
so and in that paper she shows how
um you know this exchange
of
protection
to mitigate risks
against political support
leads to
a situation where
um can create more inequality in rural
setting
and only changing
the changing agricultural technology for
instance can
undermine this personalized relationship
between
you know the political elite and tenants
so
overall
public investment
private investment
are
can be distorted
by unequal power
but also by
connections
by by incentive of government to be able
to to to want to
to selectively serve
you know some consistencies particularly
co-ethnics in the case of kenya okay so
now let's move from uh
water-induced distortion from what i
from firm induced distortion
which is commonly known as a commonly
called political connection
so
a seminal paper
uh in that along this line is by fishman
that shows
how
um
sowato's health
can affect stock prices
of
firms that
connected
to to suharto
and uh
you can see the relationship here you
know a negative
correlation
between
um
news about sohatu health and uh stock
prices
and um
this polycarbonate connection is
becoming a central central uh issue
in many developing countries
and there are uh there is a descriptive
uh data sets by facio showing foreign
how this common this widespread this
phenomenon are of political connection
between firms and
and and and
politicians and
one implication of this connection is
the effect on innovation
using the model
that i just described you earlier about
the schumpeterian model
so um
beats and quarters show that in in italy
firms
that are more likely to be connected
they tend to innovate
less
and
despite the fact that connections reduce
their cost
and they have supporting evidence um to
show how
you know
political connections um reduce
incentive to invest
uh
you know
using
you know rdd exploiting um you know idd
on close close elections so
um
the key point here is that an incumbent
firm can choose to entrench itself in
investing in political connection to
deter innovators
entry
and industry industries with more
political connection have less
innovation
older firm
and i mean an older firm tend to be less
productive okay
so
um
[Music]
so far i've talked about um
how
political connection is widespread and
how firms can benefit from those
connections
the literature the current literature
have talked about how those benefits can
come about
so i'll basically
um
cover a couple of uh a couple of papers
that dealt with
you know the the mechanism
one will be focused would be evidence
from pakistan and another one from
lithuania
so
um on pakistan
the way political connection is measured
is by membership board membership
in private bank
by uh
sorry in public bank by uh by
politicians
and those the firm with politician board
member they receive 42 larger loans
and 50
higher default rates
and the effect is driven by government
banks so no private banks here
and uh
you know
what is fascinating in that paper is
that
the preferential treatment
increases with political strength
measured by
the
victory margin
of a politician in a in an election
and also by the level of participation
electoral participation in the district
wherever politician is running
you know so
and we also uh measured
the
gdp loss
due to this distortion and we find for
instance that uh
you know
um
[Music]
the lower bound of 0.15 to 0.03 gdp loss
and the higher estimates and addition
went 1.6 percent so you can see
how
political connection affect um you know
the economy as a whole
in terms of gdp loss
so another
effect of um
of
political connection is through
procurement
and um
there is a very interesting paper um in
2012
uh you know
covering the
campaign contribution ban that was
implemented in lithuania in 2012
and
they show the bidding behavior
they contract the billing behavior of
firms that made campaign contribution
versus those who did not make thanks
completion you can see before the ban
that takes place here
the building behavior very very
different but then it converge
after the ban
so it shows
that political connection
bought
with campaign contribution has strong
effect on building behavior
okay
so there are other
works
covering
probability of bailouts
loan from state bank lower taxation
easier easier access to import licenses
regulatory captures
and so on and so forth
so
i think a major challenge
to development comes from political
connection and there is a wide range of
evidence to support that
so now let's move to
state capture
it's a case where
distortion are systemic and entrenched
where there is some kind of distortion
trap
even in competitive electric even when
there is completive elections
so
we we call
this a situation a crony capitalism
which is very very common um
in countries
that have legacy or developmental states
like in asia north africa
but also
currently
in russia and many eastern european
countries
okay
so
um
one
important
area of state capture
is um
international corporations that
basically
you know through a wider pressure
by domestic governments
and even sometimes have the power to
appoint ministers particular ministry of
finance this was the case in togo guinea
and this has also been um you know the
case in uh in south africa
so
one
interesting dimension of state capture
is
the ability
of
firms
to use different form of state capture
direct form of state capture
where
the
the firms work with bureaucrats
to implement distortion
you know like favorable tax rates or
rigging
procurement
or they can also use indirect form of
state capture which is
the control politicians through campaign
donation
and then the politicians control what
the bureaucrats will do
so and what um
we found in this paper
is that
when
the electro when
the electoral process is competitive
firms use
direct form of state capture
as an insurance
against
potential loss
due to the fact that the politician that
they support would be out of power
so
and we find evidence
that
when the winning margin in local
elections in benin increases
the form of state capture that the firms
use
is direct
they tend to go after bureaucrats
who have longer tenure in office
than
politicians
and what is interesting is is that
there is the result this correlation
this um you know this correlation
between form of state capture
and
competition electoral competition is
presence
in municipal elections not in
legislative elections as you can see
here because
alleged elections i mean mps do not
control
the bureaucrats they don't have control
of bureaucracies
they don't have any direct connection
with bureaucracy you know so
and we use a placebo we need margin
between the second and the third runner
in the local elections and we find no
effect
okay
so
what this shows in a very powerful way
is that
even in competitive elections
you can still see
distortion
because
politicians will switch
from one form to another
and
if this is the case
it shows that
it you know first
market i mean distortion
might be
my
might still be present
with increased electric competition
but also we've improved
bureaucrat selection
and in the model i mean i mean the model
and also in the empirical layers that we
have done we show that distortion
decreases when you have improved
politician selection
so
sometimes democracy works
in curving
holocaust distortion
sometimes it doesn't
particularly when
police firms have access
directly to bureaucrats if democratic
capture is possible
so
in that case
political selection is key
you know you need to go after we need
the process to generate
politicians
that are not connected
to firms
you know and you can generate some
internal competition in political
parties the process you can also
encourage for instance grassroots
mobilization
and
you know you can use many strategies for
instance to be able to detect
and to isolate
connected politicians and that way
the political selection can lead to um
you know
a decrease in um
uh you know in political distortion
so
okay now let me let's now finish by uh
um
discussing
how you deal with it you know and i
think this is clearly my favorite part
of the talk because
um
what i've shown so far
is that growth
is
political
state capacity and
the political process play an important
role
so
political economy should be
less backward looking in terms of
trying to find out how historical
institutions affect growth today but to
be more prospective and prescriptive
you know the
the
the
the version of political economy that i
think could make the best contribution
to growth
is the one that deals not only with what
to be done but how this could be done
you know and there is a growing
literature trying to deal with that
studying for instance with um
you know banning
lobbying i mean limiting lobbying ban
income campaign contribution
you know limiting the extent to which
firms can
basically
support financially political campaign
in many countries
and there are a lot of laws across
africa and latin america to deal with
these issues so that's that that's
clearly progress
but then
um
there is a growing literature on public
management
and
it's about audits and government
contract for instance and taxes
um
monitoring
that close losses to consumers given
political agent behavior
and anticipation of disclosure
that potentially
cause politicians to shift public
investment
so and christian's fantasy is really
important it's something that can be
done
and it has proven to be very effective
another is technology you know that
works
on id cards digital collection of taxes
invoicing
voting
and
regulatory reform public procurements
work
overall
it's proven a very promising avenue
to reduce distortion
so
and as i said earlier a key to
[Music]
chinese
economic growth
is
not only
um
the politics
that creates
some
sort of consensus
among the elites
about growth
it's only it's all it's also about
decentralized
sorry decentralization
um you know public management policies
meditation
those state reform public management
reforms that in fact um has a very very
important effect on growth so
now the second um is political selection
so
um
there are massive literature on how
providing information
before
during election before election can
help um
can affect voting behavior
and
there are a lot of focus on the type of
information
type of campaign promises
that will affect
um
voting voting behavior
or the incentives of politicians to do
the right thing
to make the right level of public
investment
but
overall the evidence is mixed
and
i think
in my view
it's not
about whether information works or not
it's what type of information under what
conditions information should be
effective
and it depends on the relevance of the
information it's all depend on the power
that embryo has to have to act on the
information
so it's important to to consider the
institutional setting
of the information
uh when the information is provided
so that we can make
um
information provision
as
a way to improve transparency and
accountability
in
government
okay
so
political selection is not just a demand
for good type of politician but also
supply of of good type of politicians
there are recent work for instance
trying to find to create environments
where
good politician
development promoting politician
will emerge
there is um
you know townhall building
policy deliberation during campaigns for
instance
can help
kind of clean up
to some degree
have a political process
um
and also
primaries
in
which citizens have
some say
into who will run for office from
different parties
can also help us you know
select
better uh
politicians or motivating politicians
um by um
by using
uh basically
uh by incentivizing uh
the
personal
versus the social value of running for
election
how this can actually help this and what
uh one and one interesting paper shows
that when this selection process
happened publicly
the political pressure
can get you know politicians to actually
have a
better politician development promoting
politician um you know to um
to arise
now
um
one important
political distortion is lack of
representation particularly gender
representation
for obvious reasons
so
all the work on gender quota
on incentives provide an incentive for
women to run for office
are also
a part of political selection
you know more representative political
process so this is critical now let me
finish by talking about
what i call public reason
and social contract
um it's it's a it's a it's an ambitious
um
kind of concept
developed by political philosophers
particularly by macedo
my colleague from princeton
that states that the liberal ideal of
public reason
hold that those advocating for law and
policies
ought to offer adequate supporting
reason
that could be shared by all reasonable
members
of the community
is the idea
that
policy should be based first on evidence
on reason
and those reasons has to be made public
and has to
aim at getting a reasonable individual
to agree
so
and i think it's such a powerful concept
for
that
for the discussion debates on reducing
political distortion
because the technical part of political
distortion which is we discussed by
saying well public management you know
the fact that political selection is not
enough
because of
one piece which is missing political
selection perhaps is
public reason and social contract
that's why
the evidence on participatory governance
um
i mean literature on participatory
governance
is important but unfortunately
even there
the result has been mixed
and the reason why it's mixed
in my view
it's because of the design
and also
because
sometimes it's public
not enough reason
you know so
it's not enough to get people in the
room to debate
you need the debate to be anchored by
evidence
by logic
you also need
as a goal
to get people to agree to get people
to commit
and
so
this is
this is the the the
the logic
behind a project that i'm currently
conducting
in nigeria a very ambitious project
where we have an intervention
in several states
and that intervention has three steps
the first step
is information gathering dissimulation
on policy preferences
deliberation through what we call
education summit
and the drafting of a social contract
so if i can show you
what it looks like um so basically
um
the question in in that project
is
to
to look at the effects of that
intervention as described
on the policy design and priorities
stakeholder buying investment in reform
and looking at two set of mechanisms one
is information
and and the other one is
empowerment
so
um the project timeline look like this
so there is a summit
where there is policy dialogue
before the summit data collection and
post summit
um
you know
ensuring that
everyone
basically have a minimum understanding
of what needs to be done
so this is those are pictures for
instance from from the summit
you have a representative of governments
and
basically
teachers and parents and so on
and
one full day discussion incurred by
solid
by survey on priorities
on the government budget and so on
led to
a contract
some kind of written agreement
of what
education
to look like should look like
and what should be
the role and what should be
what commitment we want each
stakeholders to to have
and after that
the government's
served a work plan
that responded to
what people want
and what people um basically
decided at the meeting
and then there have been follow-up
to have
you know also the commitment from the
other side uh from parents so the
government
okay
the policy deliberation led to
commitment by government
at school level parents teachers
are informed
they also make commitment
in a written contract
you know so um
but let me
just finish by um
by telling you a little bit about uh
what we learned from this
first
i think
that
st
oh where is it
okay okay let's do that
okay yeah that's good thank you
all right that's perfect
so yeah thanks very much
so uh first
[Music]
um
one weakness of this old exercise here
is
the lack of
flexible growth model that
really integrate different aspects
of um
institutions which is
you know
public investment
contract enforcement and so on
instead of having separate model you
know uh one dealing with innovation and
market competition another one during
public investment might be interesting
to build a a coherent model you know
that cover different aspects
um
we also need to pay more attention to
you know the systematic uh sorry the
systemic
political distortion
that we call
cronin capitalism which is really
um a big issue in many many countries in
the developing country in the developing
world
and uh
but um
in some
proposing here
is
political economy
to be more prescriptive
more prospective
there is
focus on
institutional experimentation
not only experimenting with different
ways
of
you know improve public management
improve political selection
improve citizen citizens engagement
so that
political distortion can be reduced
and
an important point as well that i i
developed is the idea
that
we need to
define
political distortion
defining measuring political distortion
has to be key has been the starting
point
of political economic research that
means we need to know what things ought
to be
like
in uh
you know
in the model that i i discuss or for
instance in the work
that uh
gerard and his co-author have done in
kenya
and then
have a clear understanding of the
distortion
of what things ought to be and then
think about
institutional innovation
you know and this
can
be through
some different form of experimentation
to reduce
the protocol distortion so overall
i think political economy can be a
powerful tool for development because as
i said as we said earlier
states
and government
good or bad government account for
perhaps 50
of developing outcome
so there is an important role for
government to play
but to do that it shouldn't be
just describing
what government does is to identifying
departure from what government is doing
from what they ought to be doing
and then find ways to reduce
distortion that are generated
by
the political process thank you very
much
[Applause]
yeah so i think we have some time for uh
questions um if you have questions then
boomi has a mic up there so if you just
raise your hand she'll
come to
[Music]
hi uh thank you so much for a wonderful
lecture um one of the questions i had
was do you think that the socially
optimum level of political connections
ought to be
near zero or are there cases or
conditions under which political
connections might actually
stand in for a lack of information or
lack of state capacity so for example
when there is development when there are
development initiatives being undertaken
there is a greater move towards
engaging people who have local level
information and those are people who are
generally politically connected and so
when you say that we should have models
that
point towards an endogenous level of
socially optimum
uh political connections
would those be positive under certain
conditions thank you yeah the short
answer is yes
basically
so
we we need to think about
non-discretionary political connection
for instance um bringing
private sector expertise in regulation
in policy making
you have to be careful about conflict of
interest you have to be careful
about um
you know attempt by firms to block
entry
and so on so i think uh
private and public partnerships
can be
non-decisionary
and political process exactly as you
said
uh can be
and can be informed
uh or can can can be improved
by some type of connection with the
private sector
but you we need to find
creative way
uh to reduce uh the stationary
um you know private connection like when
we describe
thank you for that um any other
questions from the audience
thank you so much for that
very insightful lecture i had one
question
on
how you might
maybe not integrate but bring in some of
amitya sen's discussion
around the you know the role of the free
press which i think he's written so much
about
in creating uh the right kinds of
public engagement strategies
yeah i think that's a that's a very very
important point
i think the press
even social media
can help amplify
transparency
can also amplify
citizens engagement
but i strongly believe
that at
the at the start
[Music]
the
reason are important the reason is as is
is as important as
public you know it means that
discussion about public policy
discussion about
you know not only institutional design
it has to be first based on evidence has
to be first based on
some research
you know so that you can actually
um
constrain
the extent to which
you can have misinformation or you can
have
you know the press and press freedom
being used
to actually
increase distortion you know because
um using i mean taking advantage of how
vulnerable some populations are some
vulnerable
some signal society are
um you know this press
can be used in fact to enhance the
interest of some special interest i mean
of some you know of a government or some
special interest so so so so yes the
press and freedom of press is very very
important but i i think
that
evidence research
to support healthy debate discussions
um
is
really really it's really really really
important you know so yes so i will see
uh the word by amacha sen as
very
uh in line
with this idea of promoting
uh you know transparency receiving i
mean political engagement
you know ownership of policies
empowerment all those
concepts that we think have value
in
reducing distortion
the price can play a role
in uh
and in employment amplifying that but i
think
uh there is i mean my initial kind of
sense is that
you know
debate discussions engagement supported
by serious evidence and by research
that's really really really critical
yeah
thank you
thank you um we are live streaming and
there are a number of questions that
came up on the zoom so i just want to
take the chance to ask one of those so
this one concerned your findings for us
to watch on and it asks do your findings
apply to developed as well as developing
countries and if so would there be any
complications for developing countries
seeking to implement these solutions
that you propose if developed countries
don't also make the same changes i'm
sorry i i didn't understand so it's
asking about whether your findings apply
to developed as well as developing
countries and if so would there be any
complications if developing countries
are looking to implement the kind of
solutions you're proposing if developed
countries don't also make those changes
i'm not sure if understand that's part
of the question if developing if the
countries implement the same change will
it be possible to do it in the
developing countries as an if developed
if developing countries want to make
those changes would there be any
problems if develop if developed
countries don't also seek to make those
changes as well
uh i mean i'm not sure if i understand
the question properly but uh
obviously
[Music]
distortions are sometimes international
you know like
like france
us corporations might be the one
capturing domestic governments
you know the case of
gupta brothers in south africa is it's a
it's a it's a good one
so
the solution that we are proposing
shouldn't be just about developing
countries it should also be about
developed countries and their
relationship with
developing countries
you know you have to hold
you need transparency not only
domestically but assuming transparency
internationally and you need for
instance
[Music]
you know governments of france and u.s
to hold
their corporation accountable you know
the way
they have to deal with
um
you know
governments in developing countries
there are several laws
that penalize
attempt to bribe foreign governments
um to to basically to limit um you know
state capture
and i know for instance ray has was in
polar in france was um
you know he was
he has some legal issues
related to
his dealing in togo and guinea so those
are
you know i think it's linking
domestic reform with
reform in the international system you
know it's something which will be
really really important having said that
i think that there have been
in many
developed countries
you know progress in
regulation
in
in
law against conflict of interests or
or uh you know either
long experience
you know in
public
management at all level
that we can learn from that we can try
to apply
you know
similar kind of principle in trying to
reform states in developing countries so
two things so first
there are lessons learned
from you know the u.s from france and
other advanced democracies that can be
very helpful in dealing with political
distortion in developing countries
that's one
second i agree that um
finding
a
you know
you you have to deal not only with
distortion domestically
but to deal with foreign induced
uh distortion at that domestic level you
know the gupta brothers in south africa
is a good example so
you need an international system
you know not just such a domestic system
that help deal with uh
political distortion
any questions in the audience
particularly on that side we can bring
the mic over
hi
um
very comprehensive talk and highly
relevant um i want to go back to your
notes on shumpter
um
you know corruption and political action
it can be it's a motivated you know
fundamentally by
fear or opportunism
when it's motivated by fear there's fear
of loss
and the loss to the actor can be
measured
in dollars
but the cost is measured in percentage
of gdp
have you done any work or
seen any work have any thoughts on
how that
action can be mitigated because the cost
so far outweighs
the loss to the actors that are bringing
down the entire system
thank you
so much can you maybe uh for me to
understand the question better can we
give a specific example for instance of
what you have in mind um i could think
in terms of
the energy sector maybe that there
are actors in
coal
for example that they are lobbying very
hard to prevent action on
more progressive more beneficial
alternative energy that you know if
implemented we would have
cleaner air cleaner water or maybe
cheaper energy overall in the long term
but in the sharpentarian model they're
holding everything back so we don't have
the progress and the innovation that we
otherwise could have to the benefit
to gdp yeah yeah yeah so yeah i think
that's a very very interesting and very
complicated question
so uh
okay
you know
the
one
perhaps
uh way i can
think about this issue
is uh
you know
some type of government subsidy
for this emerging sector
to be able to compete
effectively from the old
but backwards
relatively the street you know
you know the destructive sector
might be important but then how
you know
how do you put in place with political
incentives
um
for more forward-looking
[Music]
governments
willing to stand against
this kind of very powerful
[Music]
you know
you know
economic interests in favor of a status
quo
so it's a it's a very it's a very you
know i think it's a
um you know i think what's currently
happening is um
i don't know
very like public debates
on
normal energy climate change
and you expect perhaps that public
opinion
will help sway
um
politicians in favor of these solutions
that might not be
um
in the short term politically beneficial
um but you know i think
the more i think about it the more i
realize how
social movement grassroots mobilization
for instance
uh
he has
great value you know
in pushing you see what i mean like
in pushing governments to deal with
those kind of tough issues you know
because i mean
um the way
you can deal with the issue you talk
about
can only be somewhat of a bottom-up
mobilization
grassroots you know that would perhaps
lead to the emergence
of uh more progressive politicians
willing to take you know take on those
policies
because they know they have popular
support because they know that the
international and domestic movement in
support of those kind of policies
you know so maybe one way to counter
balance
um the status quo
um
you know besides science you know it
could also be
you know like a grassroot mobilization
you know so i think
[Music]
glass mobilization has
can have economic value
especially
when the sector
that
the progressive sector that you said
do not have the political clout and the
resources to compete
um against uh
you know so you can think of a champagne
model
where
[Music]
uh the the
curbing destruction uh
it would include
political selection
that
requires
a very strong
grassroots
popular
movement
you know so
yeah and i think
the current climate change consistency
that may not have been that we have some
little support from the green energy
sector
um but it's very powerful very vocal
young
um you know it could be a good
way
to
balance
you know
um
the incentives that lead to
this
innovation this progress
being possible so my immediate answer to
your question will be let's go to the
people
let's get them to revolt let's uh
let's get them to speak out loudly
mobilize young people get them to yell
at whatever you know and then maybe
something is possible you know so i'm
going back i'm going back to my
you know
to my days in the 80s you know where i
thought that you know you know
when nothing is possible
get young people in
on the streets and perhaps uh
you know they can be the balance
we can provide
the you know the support that you need
for for for progress
so i think that's
that's what i will say you know i mean
if you look at um
um you know like in the 70s and 80s i
mean it's not about climate change
you're not about um
but you know it was in the best
interests of
powerful elites to maintain the status
quo
um you know
oppressive
anti-freedom
and so on and
we have support from international
corporations you know from the u.s and
france and you know
and so on look at chile you know but
then you have popular mobilization you
know student movement
and student unions
that
provided you know
the support needed for
the emergence of an alternative
political elite that made
change political change democratization
you know
they are democracy possible
because i mean like
it was not clear from the beginning that
democratization was economically
rational you know
uh given that many
countries in the west were supportive of
autocrats so that they can control
natural resources and this kind of stuff
but then you have
the counterbalance coming from social
movement that help democracy
you know to arise in these countries so
it's a very complex question i think uh
on the spot that that's what i can say
thank you
i think that's a really good segue and
to another question that we've just
gotten through um on the zoo so this is
asking are you concerned all by
political distortions by big tech um
since they can influence people's
actions at a grassroots level via
smartphones
i'm sorry so are you concerned by about
political distortions by big tech firms
so i guess facebook twitter and so on as
it can influence how people act at a
grassroots level using their smartphones
so big tech
can
do what i'm saying sorry it can
influence people's political influence
how people are viewing politics
and using their smartphone
wow that's a very
that's a very interesting question so
for instance
um if we think that
public reason is the way to go and
technology can
amplify
um
basically what people i mean can shape
what people think
can it be in the best interest of tech
companies
not to serve
the public as a whole but serve their
own interests
so yeah i think it just confirmed why we
also need the regulation the tech sector
so that
we can remain
so that we can
make
the tech sector as politically neutral
as possible
we can prevent you know like for
instance if you look at what's happening
with facebook you know that was in their
interest to distort information so that
they can sell
you know
so there is a rising interest in
regulating
social media and tech companies
um you know
and i think this will be
you know
i think one way for me to answer this
question you know by saying for instance
that
[Music]
tech companies might not necessarily act
in the interest of the general public
in the interest of economic development
and progress
they might have some other incentives so
regulation of
this
is also is necessary you know to protect
um
basically you know
to protect the political process against
extremism against divisive discourse and
and so on and so forth
yeah
so
that's my initial
reaction to the question
okay thank you um we've got time for one
more audience question
[Music]
um thank you very much professor um in
your lecture you mentioned how
co-ethnics as well as competition affect
political distortion
but you didn't mention ideology and i
was wondering whether there has been any
research into the
ideology of political parties and how
that affects the level of political
distortion in a state
no i think that's a great question
ideology
can act as
ethnicity you know
you know you can there is a parallel
between
basically
ethnic identity and
ideological
identity
i mean identity based on ideologies
and
[Music]
so in the u.s for instance very
polarized
politics
um you know obviously you have racial
divisions but then
um
[Music]
the
the gap between republican and democrats
shaped by ideology in part
can be
as
destructive can be as this distortionary
as ethnic
divisions
and so yeah i would say in some
countries what we call ethnicity could
be religion in other countries could be
ideology
sometimes it could be even be regions
and trench interests that are originally
based
that creates
this distortion distortion exists so
long as one party find in the best
interest to serve
that group at the expense of other
groups
you know so
so i think that's uh
that's what i can say so um
you know
one
you know okay so let me put this way um
and i think
that
um
you know one of the concern that some
philosophers have about public reason
is the fact that in polarized societies
it will not lead to
consensus but lead to maybe more
division
and the argument
that the political theories make
is that
even in a polarized society
it's worth trying to build a consensus
even if you achieve it or not
it's worth
trying to find reasons
for us to work together to find reasons
why
we should be less divided
you know
and if the reason exists and you are
patient enough
then you can overcome
those divisions you know so so so so the
point here
is that
ideologies ideological differences
[Music]
are
act like
acne differences in many contexts
but even then
there must be
institutional setting there must be
institutional
innovation
that
try to bridge the divides
and
you know
one key element i think is
putting forward
the needs for collaboration the need for
consensus building
whether this works in the short term or
not you know and and i think uh
uh anyway so that's that's what that's
what i can say so i think i agree with
you entirely
but i i i think that um
um
but
there is a solution
you know it can be institutional that is
maybe one last question if you don't
mind
yes
we are out of time but maybe um
[Music]
my name is sahara karimi i am a film
director from afghanistan i am just
visiting pro like
visiting small professor and also
visiting filmmaker here
from uh
very far afghanistan but accidentally i
just entered to your
your class because we are we're
preparing for this screening of my film
and i just catch a few few sentences i
would like to ask
mr professor that
i am come from this country that
unfortunately
we have many many problems like we have
problems ethnical problems we have
problems political problems and
everything is so
complicated and america
20 years ago came to my country with
this big slogan that we are going to
solve your issues we are going to
motivate you to to be united we are
going to save your country because you
are you have many many issues and during
last 20 years we were practicing being
united and we were my generation we were
quite good and we were very very active
participant
and today i am in america and i am here
i am showcasing my films i am showcasing
those
achievements that we achieved during
past 20 years in a country that somehow
signed a peace deal with the most
terrorist group in the world with the
most ideologies group in the world with
the most pro-ethnic group in the world
and somehow we by this deal they divided
us they divided my generation they
divided my country they they put
new new and very old conflict between us
what do you think about the policy of
america about us about my country and
many countries that america is now
trying to to divide it you know
thank you
so um i have i'm tempted but
say that's a very very complicated
question which is
uh a bit above my pee degree
[Music]
all i can say is that i wish the best
you know for
afghanistan and for
all the countries that
have similar set of issues and um you
know
as a research community
we
you know i'm pretty sure we have to
contribute to thinking about
how could
afghanistan have been dealt with
differently you know so um
i think roger madison has a paper on
on that using the experience of british
um colonialism
um indirect rule by saying
maybe there was a better way
to
um you know to
to deal with
know the country you know i don't know
so the point of what is made um open
question
so i feel sorry that
it's what it is but for hopefully um
we we we can get out of the current uh
crisis thank you
and
please join me in thanking leonard for a
fantastic lecture thank you very much
you